2015 was a wonderful year for video
games and if you are like me you're
already looking forward to january and
all the games that are gonna come out in
2016 Peter brand Mike McCarty alexa ray
career let's go through it let's get
2016 hype are you hype yes you hype Mike
yeah you're always hope I am that's my
thing your brown looks like get ahead of
ourselves here okay okay power back I'm
just a cynical he didn't realize you
with this one how I'm bad XCOM 2 coming
in February Oh excited for that it's not
get ahead of ourselves here I actually
am NOT a huge ex-con fan so I mean I'm
glad to see that game is coming back and
people are excited for it yeah well
diamond went off and played a bunch of
it last week I think I'm so excited for
exile to I'm extremely excited fact some
too I'm not gonna be tellin ya so uh
enemy Unknown an enemy within both
unreal like different blend of just
squad tactics and overall strategy
within right now on the ipod yeah oh and
i'm just really excited for like more
units more enemies its kind of this cool
new take on the world where it's 20
years after and the aliens have already
won so you're more of a rebellion than
an actual like Defense Force yeah and
you there's so many small things I'm
really excited about you can carry squad
mates when they're wounded you can carry
them when they're dead and you just need
their gear which is pretty morbid but
you still let me clear layer but you can
also like when you go into some missions
you're in stealth as opposed to
automatic like the aliens knowing where
you are so yeah kind of complete
objectives theoretically just without
them knowing you were there and I'm a
big fan of stealth and ex-con so kind of
blending those two seems pretty
appealing to me overall it just sounds
like you know if they take what made the
first games grey and make it better that
should be awesome yeah and we've seen I
guess a lot of people that sort of MOBA
genre expand out into different genres
and next year is kind of went the first
person MOBA chickens will come home to
roost we're going to have overwatch and
battle born within the first half of the
year yeah hero shooters hey there I've
should any any takers for either of
those games because they are kind of
going up against each other in a way
although one I don't want consoles and
what pc news well ma I play a little bit
of both and like I hate MOBAs cuz MOBAs
are for nerds so I I played a little
final fantasy I play
I played a little a little bit of both I
played them at events and I overwatch I
really like the style of overwatch and I
really like the setup of overwatch
however like I don't know what I'm doing
going into those games so when I was
playing at events i would get sniped
this year i walked out so that needs
some balancing I don't a mistake I think
that's a kind of an event problem yes
you have because we played a blizzcon
and myself italian Andy bellman just
smoked everyone because we were playing
as a team because we were there together
I I have played so much overwatch like
it's weird we're talking about like the
best first-person shooters that came out
this year we played this year this is
the best FPS up late this year it's just
not officially out yet because that
outfit was pretty a pretty it wasn't
what it was pretty closed and so I'm
really excited for this ya know
overwatch is great but with the
battleborn so I played I think a lot of
what makes battleborn charming is the
character thing like I think battleborn
is going to be the game for people that
like to latch on to a character and play
a game because of a character whereas
overwatch will be the game for people
that want that hero shooter hmm I i I've
warmed to the characters no watch more
as well maybe because I haven't played
much battle born there seems to be more
of it like visitors are so good at that
in a way that I don't know this seems to
be so disparate with like mushroom dude
and you know some of them are penguin
that right okay the penguin urbex pretty
cool especially cuz rajbhandari does the
voice for anyone play battleborn anyone
yes we got to play some of the coop
campaigns something I guess they're
saying it's story-driven but that even
that's pretty bare bone but in general
yeah it seemed there it's definitely
going for the same thing is over
watching I guess battle cry to some
extent but oh yeah but that's been
pushed back as well right it's it's a
cool concept I mean in terms of this if
you want a story out of these games
which isn't like a huge drawing force
but you know like there's one more star
in the galaxy everybody's converging on
but it really i mean this is nico
they're using right now the mushroom guy
you mentioned and his kind of he's more
of a support character and he can heal
but I don't know I it still got that
whole you know different carrots are the
different abilities that you can kind of
experiment with I could see myself
putting a few hours into it it's gonna
be interesting to see which one of those
sort of rises to the top and a game that
has the story that people are very
interested in March 18th we're going to
finally get uncharted for a thief sent
any takers for that one yeah I love
everything Tye route does so I
nightmare times yeah what does what does
the deal with it with it what is it what
is the deal with with with the choosing
of the branching like the storyline
stuff that seems like that's probably
just like pretty soft level right yeah
well we have no idea we I'm sure they're
gonna flick a switch after the deficit
like what a way to test an audience by
giving them like that little taste and
seeing how people react to it all right
maybe nobody wants that they could
easily just turn it off if it was a
thing and I don't think anybody wants it
it doesn't make sense to me like these
games seems seem to be thinner waited no
get roller coasters that you know when
you play a part it's in a sequence that
is like action packed it's not during
this like moment where you're trying to
make a poignant decision with your
brother you haven't seen in 10 years
like what what game is that that's not
charted ride the roller coaster you want
to be the guy pulling the lever I'm
guess it I'm really interested to see
how this game shakes out because the
original writer is no longer oh yeah
again the series Amy heading left in her
she's working on any Star Wars game and
I don't know I feel like I feel like if
she was around maybe the dialogue
choices wouldn't be a thing so I'm sort
of cautiously optimistic like I'm gonna
play cuz it's a uncharted spin a great
series but i do think maybe story wise
mmm to Drake I gave your Excuse rocky
draw a Drac I i think is what we called
him and again do we haven't seen much of
a little bit on e3 which definitely sort
of got the taste buds of watering June
2016 week or mm-hmm Peter brand excited
for that yeah I I like things that keiji
inafune he does he tends to doing a lot
of them at the moment he's doing a lot
of them at the moment it's also a very
misunderstood guy hmm rather than focus
on the controversy surrounding is other
projects this is one that is really
interesting to me because not only is it
a cochina fuuny joint it is an armature
Studios joint and the thats to do is run
by a lot of guys who used to work on
metroid prime right which is one of my
favorite like little like mini series of
all time and you know it it's
interesting because it sort of does the
Mega Man Thing and that one of the
characters can kind of transform and
have different abilities in this case by
being implanted into something rather
than like taking on a thing but but yeah
like we still don't know too much about
it but I'm willing to sort of be on you
know for a change optimistic yeah we'll
see look at those people on the couch
they're different to the people that's
right now it's the same couch though
getting out we got a bunch more game so
that's rush to a couple more at doom we
will see maybe next year that's a first
person shooter yeah its software I'm
making good luck to them hopefully I'll
be cool and really really rush there is
great though I play Baltic you have yes
yeah many people have there was an open
beta recently is it like it's like quake
okay it's really fast and it's really
fun and I had started givin up on doom
during the e3 presentation but when Iowa
to quakecon and play the multiplayer
total about-face maybe I don't care
about the campaign that multiplayer is
awesome great there you go multiplayer
in a doom game is your review hey I know
Matt's guy didn't command 2015
apparently coming out like if we could
be three or something yeah that's gonna
give my mare for them and yeah looking
forward to that one i'ma catch ya it is
a crazy experiments that I think will
like I'll be curious to see the
long-term benefits of what they're
trying to do and how the community
latches on to it because they're
supposed to be like 64 Quinn no 18
quintillion planets yeah in this yellow
you've never ever get anywhere close to
like finding one person oh no of course
but like but the method in which that
you know they're creating all of these
things is kind of obvious but also
ingenious and the way they've
implemented it and then you add on this
sort of seamless transition from space
to Terra Firma like it's this it's the
definitive open-world game I can't think
of a game that tries to tackle that at
such a scale any better than this yeah
even if the sort of the gameplay is
going to be relatively restrictive as it
seems to be no it seems to be pretty you
know you go I've mine for stuff upgrade
your ship so you can explore further
like we'll see how many legs that has
like it just as a concept it seems like
it's gonna be so much fun especially not
a girl has made it all the way back to
earth naughty naughty boys finished
dying it's it's finally hello you call
it not being dhabi boy what you know we
know me boy novia novia know we know me
boy I prefer noby noby obvious reason 3
Navia naughty boys another game that
we're dying to play which we saw more
uppity literally dying dying The Last
Guardian yes seriously yeah stretch it
out it looks great bossa paint on it yes
I still know nothing about what it is
gonna be a you know plug puzzle
platformer with a big old dog
thing a boy dr. Griffin kind of thing
and his awkward gait eco but instead of
a little girl it's this disaster little
boy look at him are you still cute
looking but he's going to get you killed
he's also gonna die oh yeah is there
yeah I know yeah my god like stressful
yeah top picks for 2016 characters who
died is Nathan dragon brother and this
thing well what it does and then from
its corp corpse emerges a baby version
of itself oh the cycle of life begins
mean it was off in the sky like a
phoenix and this I hope that's not it
like I really hope he doesn't die I
really hope that's not what this is
setting out to go a lot guardian that's
why there's not a baby what if they
ascend to heaven together so there is a
heaven let's not gonna be here okay yeah
okay again this is getting into some
pretty deep topics though which
hopefully will play next year is cuphead
oh yeah yeah seems of a struggle of
classes you guys played you know I've
only watched it but that's enough for me
to run play oh really hard I found our
plane at pax and I remember it took me a
while like even get my head around the
fact everything yeah we did it was more
of a contra than it was oh yeah oh yeah
between crouching and actually the
bosses them it's all just boss's boss
yeah and you're going between these each
boss and I was trying to find the
easiest one during the demo and none of
them were and apparently I suck at it
but maybe I'll get better looking
forward to is fun but it just it's
beautiful to it done an amazing job yeah
pretty hand drawn right correct yeah
that I worry the accessibility is gonna
become an issue and that game might not
do so hot on the multiplayer space side
of things for honor look interesting
that guy is fun yeah it was fun as heck
you there's a play like chivalry and all
I mean like that or is it easier to
control because it's the same kind of
like yeah walking in yeah there's like
the three you have like a triangle so
like there's a top and the side and
aside and you can block or hit or
whatever and it's one of those games
where you sort of have to be on a
headset talking to someone right like I
played at PAX with a friend and we were
in a team of four and she and I had each
other in the headsets and we're like
okay you capture you have to capture
areas and defend them while also
capturing areas so it's like all right
you staying and you stay and defend this
I'm gonna go capture and then she'd be
like I need backup and I would go and
then she switched
like you really have to communicate with
the people on your team which I actually
really like that it's it sort of
simplifies that and simplifies the
amount of actions that you need to do
but it's really fun I really like it
also it looks really pretty it's like
multiplayer dynasty Warriors this yeah
it's like multiplayer dynasty warriors
without the dynasty warriors it's weird
cuz like there seems to me like I feel
like there's been a bunch of these games
flying around on steam for the past five
years but this is the first time
somebody were like triple-a pedigrees
really taking a swing at it get it
anyway it was a lot of fun it was really
well at horizon zero dawn there's a game
that we didn't really know much about
and then people got super excited of it
add the light of day gorilla are making
something other thing kills up yes looks
great it looks like far cry third person
with dinosaurs and some weird cyberpunk
aspect so it's nothing like wrong wit
that with dark so it's far cry primal
the new luggage near affordable prices
no probably right there Raptors probably
one in there so much this is 0 this is
such a weird blend like that you see her
and you assume it's going to be some
sort of like even I don't know like you
said Far Cry primal but then the
dinosaurs themselves are made out of
like some sort of machinery or the
robots man yeah what I'm worried about
this game is that they've shown it off
like a couple times III being the
biggest when it was revealed every demo
they show takes place in the same little
area yeah with them approaching this
enemy in a different way and that's well
and good and proves that the system
works but there's God is there not
something more tantalizing that they can
show us it's usually not a good sign
when the best thing you have is like one
vertical slice and you iterate upon that
for months on end in terms you know in
the public eye my fingers crossed we'll
see a lot more this but I hope so it
knows that and the Final Fantasy 15
approach may go you showed the same
vertical slice over and over delicious
when the slice tastes that good and
speaking of wild lands Ghost Recon
wildlands may be coming in next year as
well I what is he talking about how it
goes we don't want that that was the
show that quite surprised to be three
right yeah it's nothing me Oh Ghost
Recon again open-world third-person
ghost recon and you you're taking down
the cartel and you can kind of decide
whether to get they showed the same demo
well sorry the same area twice how did I
miss this once they went in like a head
sniper up here and it's like stealthily
kind of extracted the guy they're going
forward the next they went in just guns
blazing write it out like a Jeep I mean
it doesn't sound like it's anything
crazy
new but if they can kind of use like
ghost rebounds always really controlled
well now shoot that guy it's like
multiplayer looks like your test sells
drugs right yeah that's a good
comparison it's kind of like what you
could do in Metal Gear I guess if you're
being stealthy or it's just so proud of
you still t look at it it's great no
thank you lord yes it maybe take some
drugs in a brother truck doesn't know
how to drive properly Cassandra looking
for cuz it was the drugs and game we
haven't seen much of it all and fingers
crossed is either getting delayed for a
new console or it's just taking on add
the new zelda game will we see that next
year will it be on DNX I'm willing to
bet that it will be on both Lashley hmm
Twilight Princess that's a pretty safe
bet I mean it's a safe bet but like if
we also believe that recent patent that
got out that Nintendo engineers names
were attached to for the new controller
yeah you have to imagine anything in
tendo's doing well especially game as
big as this take advantage of that right
they've done it with the gamepad for the
wii u so i'm curious if they're actually
going to retool it just for the NX but
then also put it out on with you I mean
I suppose they could and just not go too
deep into that new controller and all
those weird aspects of mine introduced
but yeah I think this game is going to
come out regardless of the platform next
year for sure fingers crossed thing I
hope yeah on the same sort of Nintendo
front kingdom hearts 3 as well same as
head over Nintendo oh yeah I don't know
dude but I get a same weird us Danny
Japanese games front we're not getting
together for like two years this game is
not coming out next year one hundred
percent no I totally not they have one
more prequel game coming out Kingdom
Hearts 2.8 final chapter prologue barf
which has to come out next Oh a Nintendo
oh um no this game is like they're still
announcing worlds they've barely shown
us much of what's going on this game is
2017 at the earliest it's not coming out
next year especially with file fancy 15
they're not gonna blow they're too big
JRPG loads in one year absolutely not
don't blow your load you know he's
blowing too low though I apologize for
saying X and Xbox gonna blow three loads
on us next year I've got the me right
here there are final three games on my
list sorry first of all who's excited
for our use of for sure yay yes good
serious I know Mary kishes waited for it
Mary yes I did excited for it
right there she's freaking out right now
saying they've set her down going back
to like no horror roots that one head I
hope they do because I thought the first
game was hard I thought that demo i have
seen at e3 in a long time yeah this
thing was shaved arms nothing was going
on two characters so I don't have a clue
where they are other I'm intrigued I
don't know it just looks so weird look
at this thing it's a go [ __ ] Mongoose
I gotta shoot it shoot at her mom why
you gotta shoot it you dumbass what kind
of mongooses do they have an iron lung
guy manga I don't know well hopefully
it'll be good it'll be a cover shooter
they're real hot Peter scowling it's
like blood-borne but with gears of war
and no lights I'm so sick of old ip's
really well then well then Microsoft's
all the two loads are new ideas the
first one from the good people at remedy
it's a quantum break quantum why did you
say it like that that's how he speaks so
a midi man ready what's Emily say I'm
like yeah Alan least a month on break
well I'm look I'm uh I'm assembling from
remedy and this is a quantum break it's
weird because initially I thought it was
actually gonna use time mechanics more
than it looks now it looks more it's
kind of like bullet time from Max Payne
but then just really fast body-slammed
ashes yeah um press X to body slam yeah
the TV show has been rolled back so now
it's on the disk it's got a good thing
probably twice man Bobby Drake I he's in
the know or he's all he's better than I
guess but he's still in it and he's yeah
3 time little fingers a bad guy
apparently oh yeah look see your travel
through time to be the village that's in
the same university Game of Thrones
friend I'm in the final load my
girlfriend's Microsoft you made your bed
I'm so sorry is a crack den yeah yeah
you know the most exciting thing about
crackdown is the stuff they're doing
with the cloud mm-hmm like yes let's try
finally in the game yeah no more not
another I mean today this is the one
game that has finally proven to me and
it is great it was only in an isolated
demo microsoft said it was like real
world scenario where like we don't have
there's there's not going to be a next
gen that we care about right this game
is introducing a thing where you have
the power of like 25 xbox one's you know
from multiple servers coming together
and it proves itself when you watch in
higher buildings like huge cityscapes
crumble without the game skipping a beat
like yeah just cause 3 can do some stuff
that's pretty cool this game is like
that times 10 it is insane but the
regular game I don't know be fun for a
while right if they do it well with me
but everything maybe I mean well the
cloud stuff is only going to be
multiplayer it's not gonna have to do
anything with the same player game and I
loved the original crackdown the second
one just seemed to iterate on it with no
real added value I don't know what
they're gonna do to make this yeah
something new right if it's just more of
the same anything a minute ago i'm tired
of more of the same yeah i guess we'll
have to wait and find out 2016 is when
that's coming at i'm sure i forgotten a
couple first when it comes to mind
actually is the division hopefully we'll
see that next year as well that we soft
need to get that out maybe then they've
hadn't have not great success with new
IP with watch dogs hopefully this would
be a great new addition to their slate
anything else that you guys can think of
that i didn't mention i'm sure talk
about Final Fantasy 15 final x 15 yeah I
haven't talked about it we didn't talk
about those Nintendo games what does it
is so sorry square so sorry big gay god
I can't believe Danny thinks said final
fantasy is a Nintendo game I think
Disney's intend Oh their basic picture
eventually Disney will buy everything
yeah I'll have a consumer saw Mary you
shadow side I said the division the
division good check Dark Souls 3 i'll
dark souls capsule to me Doctor Strange
from what I play it it's really fun it
looks like they're kind of bringing a
little more blood born into dark souls
but also keeping the franchise's
separate yeah which is great because I
know people who are souls fans don't
like blood-borne or vice versa I myself
like both so I'm kind of happy to see
them melting into one another a little
bit as long as it's still feels like a
Dark Souls game which it does so how are
how many mentioned madden 16 feet to 16
new force a game right there on annual
Fire Emblem fates is gonna be good Fire
Emblem fates so many games coming in
2016 fire 1 fire watch Deus Ex nobody
knows what that's fire what's gonna be
good fire why looks alright played it
it's like gone home only you're an older
sad guy and you do stuff and you yeah
i'm so looking around fix it up I like
it what's the way what's the exclusive
preorder bonus though another
older sad guy I don't know come back
2016 we don't time for any more let us
know what your favorite game was of 2016
one you're most looking forward to your
most anticipated game rather i should
say in the comment box below